welcome to data vis deaf dog I'm your
host maja Scaasi developer advocate for
data studio in this video we'll talk
about the connector manifest and why it
is important to have the right
information there let's get started your
connectors manifest is a special JSON
file in your app script project that
specifies certain metadata about your
connector app strip needs solve this
information to run the script
successfully data studio also needs
certain information from the manifest to
display and execute the connector you
can find out more about app script
manifest in general in the link below
app script automatically creates and
updates the project manifest as you
create your connector and make changes
in that strip editor however there are a
few properties that you'll need to
update manually for your connector first
is the data studio property all
information about your connector will be
added under this property some of this
information is mandatory your
collector's name is limited to 28
characters you'll need to provide the
name of the developer or the
organization as well as the URL for the
organization you should have a logo or
icon for your connector that should be
40 pixels by 40 pixels the add-on URL
should be linked to a page that is
preferably hosted on your domain and
explains what your connector does and
how to use it this is the link users
will go to when they click on the learn
more button on your connector card the
support URL should link to a support
page for the connector users should be
able to report issues with a connector
at this link you will also need to
provide a description for your connector
this will be visible in the connector
configuration page links in this
description will be clickable it is
always a good idea to provide all
information or instructions necessary to
have a basic understanding of the
connector and how to use it in the
description this mandatory information
are required for djs studio to render
the connector interface on different
screens this information also helped the
user to know more about your connector
and explore on their own then we have
some certain optional properties under
the data studio property these aren't
required if you're building a connector
for
however if you plan to publish your
connectr you must include this optional
information in the manifest this
information help to showcase the
character in the gallery and let the
users quickly search for connectors and
filter based on certain criteria the
short description is limited 214
characters if your character is
published this short description will be
visible in the gallery card for your
connector use this to briefly describe
what your connector does users will view
this short description when they browse
through the connectors in the gallery
you'll need to provide links to your
privacy policy and Terms of Service list
the authentication type and fee type for
your connector if you want to provide a
template for your users you can list it
in the manifest the template will
provide a seamless experience for your
users since they will start with the
template instead of a blank dashboard
when they use your connector we will
have a separate video focusing on the
template experience one important entry
in the manifest is the sources your
connector might connect to one or more
sources for example if you create a
google fit connector your source or data
would be google fit to add the source
this property you first must ensure that
the source information exists in our
source registry on the data studio open
source repository if your source does
not exist there you can add it yourself
by sending us a pull request sources act
as metadata when users search for a
specific connector more information
about this can be found in the link in
the description there are two additional
properties at root level that you will
need to be aware of if you're using the
Apps Script
URL fetch app called to fetch data from
HTTP endpoints you should list all the
endpoints under the URL fetch whitelist
property this is mandatory when you're
publishing your connector you will not
be able to make calls to endpoints
outside of this list so be careful to
list all applicable endpoints including
the ones required for authorization the
second property is add scopes AB strip
automatically determines what scopes a
strip needs by scanning its code for
function calls that required them
for most scripts this is sufficient and
saves you time however for advanced use
cases like when you're using a service
account to access data you might need to
explicitly define the Scopes that covers
the basics for your connectr manifest as
we add more features to data studio and
community connectors more options might
be available in the manifest in future
make sure to check the manifest
reference link below when you're
developing your own connector you can
always go to a developer site at
developers.google.com slash data studio
for more information if you like this
video stay tuned on the GCP channel for
more of data studio content thanks for
watching
[Applause]